le 11 novembre 1918 l'armistice était
signé mais la grande guerre laisse ses
traces certains soldats mettent
plusieurs mois revenir des tranchées et
la vie quotidienne reste difficile c'est
cette période que la ville de versailles
et le comité des anciens combattants ont
choisi de mettre en avant dans leur
exposition versailles au lendemain de la
victoire de 1918
j'ai voulu me décaler un petit peu en
présentant la prémisse lice pour
démontrer d'une part que les soldats ne
sont pas revenus
enfin 18 mai beaucoup 1019 voire plus
tard et puis nous avons voulu quand même
personnaliser cette exposition par des
par une présentation de documents
appartenant aux familles versaillaise
des documents qui s'ajoutent à ceux des
archives municipales départementales et
enrichissent l'exposition
là vous avez un document qui est assez
rare qui est une lettre à l'encré
sympathique de façon à contourner les la
censure souvent donc les soldats des
poilus écrivait alors famille avec de
l'encré sympathique était révélé ce
travail est aussi intergénérationnel
depuis plusieurs années une
collaboration se fait avec les collèges
et les lycées du département
leurs productions font pleinement partie
de l'exposition et présentent leur
propre regard sur cette époque monsieur
de moura donc à rassembler plusieurs
lycées pour les faire travailler sur les
commémorations du centenaire
donc vous avez beaucoup de dessins
inquiets qui ont été faits et qui ont
été faits par thèmes ainsi vous avez ce
souvenir combattre souffrir et c'est
avec des
des dessins en rapport un travail de
mémoire de partage entre les générations
bien accompli les jeunes et benoît aussi
travailler une pièce de théâtre pour
accompagner l'exposition le grand festin
s'amener 10 novembre à 20h30 à l'espace
jean racine